Electronics keep getting smaller, and it’s
all thanks to electric switches called transistors.
When these little fellas replaced vacuum tubes,
computers went from the size of entire rooms
to merely the corner of a room.
In the 60-odd years since, transistors have
kept shrinking, scaling down and powering
up our electronics with them.
But many think we are hitting a choke point…
what if we can’t make anything smaller?!
Transistors have 3 terminals, a source, a
drain, and a gate.
Current flows from the source and, if the
gate allows the electrons to pass, out the
drain.
You know how computer code is ones and zeros
at its most fundamental level?
Well, this is where that physically happens.
Current flowing through an open gate represents
a one, a closed gate and no current represents
a zero.
Pack thousands of these transistors together
and they can do calculations and act as a
computer’s brain.
Early computers had thousands of transistors,
but one way to build a better brain is to
squeeze more transistors onto a chip, and
today’s chips could have billions.
That means scaling all the parts of a transistor
down.
Not only do smaller transistors allow for
a higher density, but it also means they can
switch from on to off faster, so small is
good!
Right now, commercially available chips typically
have transistors with gates about 14 to 20
nm across, depending on the chip.
The problem is, as gates get thinner, quantum
mechanics (the physics that govern tiny parts
of atoms) start to come into play.
For example, if the gates are too thin then
they won’t be able to stop electrons because
the electrons will tunnel through.
Not in a literal sense, they don’t bore
through the gate like an escaped convict.
They tunnel in the quirky quantum sense, where
essentially electrons disappear on one side
of the gate and reappear on the other.
Eat your heart out, Andy Dufresne.
If the gate is supposed to be closed to current
- meaning a zero - and it ain’t, that’s
a big problem.
Researchers predict that the lower limit for
silicon gate is 5 nm, and by 2021 it won’t
be economically efficient to keep shrinking
transistors.
So, where do we go when the laws of physics
stop the march of technological progress?
Well, the good news is, there are other ways
of improving performance.
Machine learning could help develop more efficient
algorithms to use with current transistors.
Or, we could switch to light based computers
with optical gates.
That, could actually boost performance 20
fold, though the hardware is a bit larger.
Or, we could stop using silicon.
Researchers have managed to make a transistor
out of molybdenum disulfide with a carbon
nanotube gate thats just one nanometer across.
It gets around electron tunneling because
electrons don’t flow as fast through the
molybdenum disulfide as they do through silicon.
But, mass production would probably be expensive,
it was hard enough to make the proof of concept.
The point is, progress can happen even if
we can’t shrink.
Keep in mind when transistors were first used
in a computer they were 20 times more expensive
than vacuum tubes.
Even though transistors were much costlier,
computer scientists knew they had more of
an upside in the long run, and look where
that led us!
...Watching cat videos on your phone while
you avoid eye contact on your commute to work.
Thanks nerds!
Make these 0’s and 1’s on your computer
work hard by making your very own website with Domain.com.
Special thanks to Domain dot com for sponsoring
this episode of Seeker!
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and have all the tools you need to build a
new website.
Start sharing your ideas with the world on a professional website. Domain.com can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot club to dot space,
to dot family or pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
For more about the problems with ever shrinking
computers, watch this video on the end of
Moore’s law and the whole new chip design they're proposing.
Fun Fact: The first point-contact transistor
was invented in 1947, and it was made from
strips of gold foil, a plastic triangle, then
pushed down on a germanium crystal.
Boy have we come a long way.
Thanks for watching